I love your show you love it yes I was
pretty funny it's funny like it's funny
yeah yesterday I was watching the show
you were featuring about the most
expensive water yeah
and sex toys honey what did you think
about the $6 oh my god that's a pachinko
right there it's really weird
[Music]
this episode is about keeping the tight
is about basically taking care of
yourself you know I mean yeah I know
your name popped up and I think we have
something for us we have the worst most
smart and expensive sleep masks and then
some yeah right yeah I don't get I get
roughly three to four hours of rest I
don't get REM so okay so we have the
latest sleep technology it's called to
my pro that uses the lighting and the
sound to get you into a meditation
session we'd like to try to Darnell yeah
it's very simple you just need to wrap
it around your head is I'm going on in
my head welcome to dream so what's going
on there so he gives you this orange
lighting is like a posing light with
lighting Chris's you breathing the light
decreases you breathe out and the whole
session takes about 11 minutes and
probably it takes 8 minutes for you to
pass out so how do you feel right now
[Music]
[Music]
pretty tranquil so opening your mind to
relaxation give you a couple more
minutes let your thoughts flow through
you think about turtles tiny little
turtles what are turtles what's under
those shells what are they hiding what
do they know it's not my voice what
thank you hey you ever see that movie
Inception like people are sleeping but
they're dreaming but there are wait but
they're not what was that is the top
spinning supposed to mean that they are
dreaming I can't remember anyway you
should just go to sleep I love you it
not only put you to sleep faster and
also attracts you're asleep using
different sensor it works with the app
and you got a sleep report next morning
breaking news 2 Chainz
sucks at sleeping and so you need to
download the app in order to hear that
voice in your head yes if you listen to
your own soul when you go to sleep with
you can just connect with Bluetooth this
has a bluetooth yes this will play
anything anything you want to play this
is amazing and not only that we can also
wash it by remove this layer and you're
able to see the super engineered
components inside of here oh so those
hardest speakers on the sides and the
lighting module this is very interesting
yeah do you know why this is so
comfortable tell me what
the material we use is for women's
underwear okay
it was very soft to me yes yes so so so
so so we are able to identify your
natural sleep trade for example you like
staying up late you like getting up
early we are able to take your genetic
information and upload down the app so
you are able to find out what kind of
sleeper you are oh I like this how much
this with this cause this cost at $299
just for the man's yes
what are they give just a minute we we
have a full packaging for the mask the
cable and traveling accessories I'm
gonna need one of these no problem I
actually have one for you right here and
this is the full packaging design award
of 2018 you see it I'm happy I have one
and the inside feels like women's
panties on your head that's crazy man
that's just amazing right there team I
love it and I appreciate the gift this
is the most expensive is keeping it
tight I'm too Chinese it's miss Tina
right here excuse